i was just listening to jd talk about
his favorite super power and
he wants to be invincible whatever that
means i mean i think he means
invulnerable like you know how the [ __ ]
would bounce off superman
yeah but like wants to be invincible
welcome to conversations with jd harmon
[Music]
jd what would you want as a superpower i
i guess like invincibility
you know no sickness or whatever i just
wouldn't be afraid of the world as much
i wouldn't be afraid of anything because
i would be invincible from it although
it would be nice to like be able to look
through walls and stuff
i would rather be invisible than have
x-ray vision you know go into like
uh high-powered meetings you know get
some uh
maybe get some stock tips that sort of
thing you know
[Music]
conversations with jd harmon
what the [ __ ] is invincible like bruce
willis and unbreakable
no he had like super strength though
yeah
and he had a whole bunch of cool [ __ ]
yeah that's
that's what i was thinking of would you
want to fly or like have
heat vision or or even
oh my god no one could ever hurt you
because you could just burn them up
you couldn't wait so lame like superman
sometimes could just fight you by
burning you up and he doesn't even do it
like you insist on coming in close and
like punching you
yeah okay yeah the problem with
invincibility
is that you can be beaten up but you
survive no is it i don't hold on maybe
maybe i understood invincibility wrong i
thought that meant you couldn't get hurt
or
you know you'd you would you could well
you said like bruce willis i'm just
saying
he could get hurt yeah bruce willis
wasn't it wasn't that cool
and then jd i want to be invisible so i
could sneak into high-powered meeting
i mean what is that you can do that now
jd
nobody knew you're there oh nobody
notices jd
yeah jd thanks robin's right you're
invisible already what do you need that
you know nobody's talking about you got
that
you know it's so true that jd has the
power of invisibility because when
before covet and we used to have
meetings jd would sit
like far away from the whole group
someone would go hey jd why are you
sitting so far away now don't
leave me alone you know i'm invisible
right like you know why he wants to be
invisible he wants to see chicks
he wants to be in high-powered meetings
what are you gonna do
invisible in a high-powered meeting
robin i was
i was i you know i don't know i wasn't
thinking i don't think these things
hear secrets you need a simple
superpower like how to talk without
mumbling
you